[Music]
get ready for Dancing with the Stars pro
gleb who transformed himself into a
Disney Prince on Monday night yes this
is not much of a stretch not at all is
it and I drop by his rehearsal with his
partner stop shot
[Music]
it is Disney Week how are you preparing
and what are you performing we're
dancing to kiss the girl oh really
and so what's the costume is Gleb Prince
Erik and in real life the Pretty Little
Liars star is engaged to her own Prince
Charming
do we have a date we're like a dress
everything is done to design my dress in
January okay names next year I'm not
stressed about it at all the 21 year old
is shedding for the wedding and says
she's lost more than 15 pounds since
joining the show it really is the best
workout I have a lot more energy I'm
feeling great I am losing weight which
is awesome especially for my wedding and
then you have to go to the boot camp
[Music]
boot camp we used to run together no
it's Sasha just Ron's piece you know and
he noticed Molly around that's nice yeah
when sasha started the show she couldn't
do one pushup
that's a complete lie by the way that
may be one push I know on her knees now
she's giving ten straight for shops like
a proper for shops that's yeah
[Music]